hubertus heil ist bei uns
bundesarbeitsminister die zahl der
infizierten erhält steigt immer noch
schnell zu schnell muss man doch mit
einer ausgangssperre hantieren weil sich
einfach zu viele menschen nicht an die
empfehlungen halten
bund und länder haben ja einschneidende
maßnahmen ergriffen um tatsächlich dafür
zu sorgen dass die menschen distanz
halten können
das habe ich noch nie gehabt die
bundeskanzlei hat recht und
gesundheitsschutz ist absolute priorität
aber ich weiß auch darauf hin dass diese
verhalten von jedem einzelnen jetzt auch
befolgt werden müssen sagt die kanzlerin
gestern gesagt und da kann es auch nicht
sein ich sag das mal ganz offen dass
leute im übermut jetzt corona partys
feiern
es war deutlich machen damit wir auch
weitere massnahmen verhindern können
ich will das nicht man muss das immer
auch alles zu ende denken muss zu ende
denken was es bedeuten würde wenn wir
jetzt zb in mietshäusern sagen leute
bleibt da jetzt wochenlang drin
wir wissen dass es dann auch ganz andere
effekte geben kann deshalb jeder muss
jetzt seinen beitrag leisten jede der
staat die gesellschaft jede bürgerinnen
und bürger damit wir es schaffen das
ziel was der droste und viele andere
führende experten gesagt haben zu
erreichen dafür zu sorgen dass unser
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet wird
wenn uns das gelingt dann sind wir auf
einem guten weg das hinzubekommen die
gesundheit der bürgerinnen und bürger zu
schützen
und darauf muss man jetzt sitzen susanne
jona ist bei uns vorsitzende des
marburger bundes internistin oberärztin
und pandemie beauftragte der
bundesärztekammer vor jona interessant
die bundeskanzlerin mahnt und empfiehlt
markus söder der bayerische
ministerpräsident droht wer trifft ihrer
meinung nach den richtigen ton
ich finde frau merkel hat den ton sehr
gut getroffen
es ist ganz wichtig an die bevölkerung
zu appellieren aber ist es auch wichtig
dass die bevölkerung den ernst der lage
wirklich erkennt und da habe ich den
eindruck dass das noch nicht immer so
gelingt dass manche auch denken ach das
betrifft mich ja gar nicht und im moment
ist es ja noch gar nicht so schlimm
oder dass junge menschen denken na ja
junge menschen erkranken nicht so sehr
da müsse sich jeder solidarisch
verhalten und mein appell ist wirklich
wir sind in den krankenhäusern für die
bevölkerung da wir hoffen die
bevölkerung leib zu hause damit wir die
arbeitslast schaffen können bei uns ist
eckart von hirschhausen mediziner
publizist moderator sind wir auf
bewährung draußen ein bisschen ja und
ich habe gerade noch mit lothar wieler
vom robert-koch-institut telefoniert ihm
macht auch die situation der
jugendlichen am meisten sorge weil
natürlich wir im moment solidarität
fordern generationenübergreifend ohne
dass wir sofort einen effekt für uns
sehen können noch sofort einen effekt
auf die infektions sein und ich hab so
kurz überlegt die zuschauer im zdf sind
ja womöglich auch irgendwo zwischen 60
und 75 die menschen die denken ich bin
ja noch nicht 80 bin ja keine
risikogruppe sind trotzdem ganz
entscheidend für diesen kampf warum die
werden wahrscheinlich nicht tödliche
komplikationen haben aber viele von
ihnen sind auch vor erkrankt werden also
auch ins krankenhaus kommen neben
anderen menschen die sehr viel kränker
werden plätze weg brutal gesagt und
worauf hören jugendliche nicht unbedingt
auf die eltern das ist altersgemäß dass
man da rebelliert was man aus will dass
man corona partys feiern will
aber wenn man sich klar macht jeder
jugendliche der vier großeltern haben
könnte wird mindestens einen davon
verlieren wenn wir jetzt nicht
konsequent und halten die distanz an die
vorschriften halten dann wird es
persönlich mein vater wird morgen 85 und
ich besuche ihn nicht und das tut mir
weh und den enkeln auch aber das ist
jetzt wichtig glaubst du
christian drosten ist bei uns virologe
an der charité in berlin einer der
bekanntesten deutschen virologen die
regierung zögert immer noch mit einer
ausgangssperre herr droste ist dafür
auch in einer woche noch zeit
ja wir haben ja schon öfter mal so
gesprochen dass das eigentlich wir in
deutschland früh dran sind mit der
erkennung unseres ausbruchs weil wir
viel diagnostik machen
wir machen wirklich sehr viel diagnostik
muss man sagen so dass man vielleicht
sagen kann es ist jetzt noch nicht zu
spät sondern wir sind so in den bereich
von einem vorlauf von der woche oder
zehn tage oder sogar zwei wochen
aber das heißt natürlich nicht dass wir
jetzt sagen können dann werden wir also
hast du zwei wochen die ausgangssperre
machen sondern wir wollen ja alle
eigentlich keine ausgangssperre und ich
glaube wir müssen aus gestalten aus
gestalten heißt überlegen wie man also
bestimmte dinge wenn man jetzt durch
berlin fährt dann sieht man eben doch
sehr viele leute noch rumlaufen bei
denen man sich denkt die fahren jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht gerade zur arbeit
wie man bestimmte dinge noch mal wieder
adressiert die zahl der intensivbetten
soll jetzt verdoppelt werden eine von
ganz vielen maßnahmen der
bundesregierung es war das auch ein
appell von professor wille vom
robert-koch-institut und natürlich
unterstützt von der bundesregierung
funktioniert in der krise jetzt doch
auch ein bisschen planwirtschaft verein
wir müssen als staat handeln wir
arbeiten auch mit der wirtschaft
zusammen und das jetzt keine zeit für
ideologische diskussion sondern für ganz
konkretes handeln um die ziele zu
erreichen und das hat uns ja in spanien
kabinett das hat uns auch professor
wieder berichtet die wichtigsten dinge
sind zwei damit wir die intensiv medizin
auch bereit haben und das hinzubekommen
ob sie können das bestätigen wir müssen
genug ärzte und ärzte haben und pflegen
das personal menschen sind da ganz
wichtig und das andere sind die
entsprechenden geräte davon haben wir
mehr als in anderen ländern durchaus
aber wir werden die kapazitäten ausbauen
müssen um im zweifelsfall menschen die
schwerst erkrankt sind gut zu versorgen
wir dürfen wir haben auch mal darüber
gesprochen nicht vergessen es gibt auch
noch andere menschen die erkrankt sind
auch zum teil schwer
unser gesundheitssystem steht vor einem
riesigen stresstest im wahrsten sinne
des wortes vor allem die menschen die da
arbeiten oder auch die da dranhängen die
zum beispiel auch betten reinigen um das
mal klar zu sagen hygiene da ist unsere
unternehmen wie zum beispiel nennt man
jetzt einen namen ausnahmsweise träger
die beatmungsgeräte machen fahren ihre
produktion hoch also wir mobilisieren
alle kräfte in diesem land und ich sag
mal bei allem was man sich in
deutschland auch mal ärgerlich langsam
vorstellt wir haben diese kräfte auch
dieses land zu mobilisieren besser als
an
wir haben einen sozialstaat der es
anders als in amerika bei allen dingen
die wir jetzt auch kurzfristig anpassen
werden aber ich will dass an dieser
stelle sagen nicht um uns in falscher
sicherheit zu wiegen das ist kein ersatz
für verhalten jedes einzelnen jeder
einzelnen wie sie das beschrieben haben
wir chancen dass wir leben schützen
indem wir uns alle individuell mit
distanz verhalten aber wir müssen auch
staatlicherseits und mit der wirtschaft
zusammen jetzt ganz schnell handeln und
gesund ist also und dann sind wir bei
frau jona auch die krankenhäuser sind
ich habe schon gesagt aufgefordert jetzt
kapazitäten zu erhöhen sich aufzurüsten
im wahrsten sinne des wortes haben sie
denn das gefühl dass alle krankenhäuser
des gleichermaßen ernst nehmen ich
glaube die allermeisten nehmen das ernst
allerdings mussten wir diese woche
tatsächlich feststellen dass einzelne
krankenhäuser den appell jetzt
verschiebbare operationen abzusagen
noch nicht ganz so ernst genommen haben
sondern dass auch noch weitergeführt
haben weil sie gesagt haben wir haben ja
noch gar nicht so viele cupid 19
patienten wir können das jetzt noch
weitermachen
es war aber natürlich so gedacht dass
man diese woche und sicher auch noch den
anfang der nächsten woche nutzt um um
etwas luft zu haben für das personal um
dann alles vorzubereiten optimal
vorzubereiten denn das erfordert planung
das erfordert auch koordination mit
verschiedenen bereichen denn es sollen
ja auch kolleginnen und kollegen dann
eingesetzt werden die sonst in anderen
bereichen im krankenhaus arbeiten die
vielleicht schon 23 jahre oder noch
länger raus sind aus der
intensivtherapie die müssen wir wieder
auf den neuen geräten trainieren und
diese dinge müssen jetzt passieren denn
wenn wir die krankenhäuser erst unter
volllast fahren dann ist nicht mehr die
zeit dafür personal was unterstützen
will und da bin ich sehr optimistisch
sehr viele wollen wirklich unterstützen
dann einzuarbeiten und den appell gibt's
ja auch nicht erst seit einer woche
sondern schon länger christian drosten
wie kriegen immer wieder etliche
warnungen aus italien aus spanien
chefärzte wenden sich direkt an die
deutschen und sagen ihr müsstet viel
konsequenter handeln
verlassen wir uns doch zu sehr auf unser
besseres gesundheitssystem
naja also
klar kommen diese warnungen aber ich
glaube zu der zeit als diese warnungen
eigentlich sichtbar wurden gab es auch
eine reaktion in deutschland das hat
dann nicht mehr lange gedauert
und natürlich ist das denn jetzt
vielleicht auch so solche warnungen sind
extrem emotional natürlich dass das löst
natürlich dann auch was aus solche
warnungen basieren nicht unbedingt jetzt
auch spezieller kenntnis der deutschen
daten situation
ich würde auch gar nicht behaupten dass
ich jetzt eine viel bessere kenntnis
hätte aber sie habe vor sechs wochen
schon in dieser sendung gesessen und
haben wörtlich gesagt es wird schlimm
richtig ja das habe ich vor sechs wochen
schon gesagt das haben sie vor sechs
wochen schon gesagt und dazwischen lag
eine zeit als auch noch mal die frage
hätten wir konsequenter und in diesem
fall eben auch schneller reagieren
können und müssen
naja also vor sechs wochen das ist jetzt
tatsächlich schon ganz schön lange her
wenn man sich das so mal rekonstruiert
damals galt das glaube ich in der
öffentlichkeit als ungewöhnlich dass ich
das gesagt habe da haben sich ein paar
leute glaube ich darüber erschrocken und
das war genau zur selben zeit als
eigentlich die
weltgesundheitsorganisation sich
durchgerungen hat von einem
internationalen gesundheitsnotstand zu
sprechen
das ist nicht ganz so fort
durchgesickert glaube ich in der
deutschen öffentlichkeit
und natürlich hat auch die
weltgesundheitsorganisation ganz schön
lange gebraucht um sich dazu
durchzuringen da hat man sicherlich auch
sehr viel rücksicht aus china geübt und
ich denke das wird vielleicht noch
kritisiert werden in der zukunft auch
wieder rosig verhalten richtig
ich glaube aber jetzt tatsächlich dass
das deutschland vielleicht gar nicht so
stark betrifft weil wir eben recht früh
dran sind im erkennen des ausbruchs also
wir müssen
ich will nicht sagen wir müssen jetzt
nichts machen wir müssen unbedingt jetzt
was machen aber es könnte sein dass wir
so gerade die kurve kriegen und andere
länder eben nicht
und nun ist schon wieder frau jonathan
beatmungsgeräte 10.000 neue sind
bestellt wie werden die jetzt verteilt
wer bekommt die zuerst war ihnen müssten
wir ehrlich gesagt auch gerne das ist
ganz ganz wichtig dass wir in den
kliniken jetzt auch tatsächlich erfahren
in welchem zeitraum kommen diese geräte
denn natürlich kann die firma die ja
auch nicht bis übermorgen liefern also
in welchem zeitrahmen müssen wir da
planen und nach und wie werden sie dann
verteilt das ist wirklich konkret für
die häuser wichtig denn jetzt werden
haben intensiv kapazitäten aufgebaut im
sinne von hier könnten wir noch ein paar
atmos gerät stellen was aber jetzt akut
gar nicht da ist und dann ist es
natürlich wichtig zu erfahren wie lange
wird das etwa dauern und das gilt
insgesamt für die materialbeschaffung in
den kliniken fehlt es oder sagen wir
sind viele bereiche knapp in der
lieferung und da sind wir dankbar wenn
die bundesregierung uns da unterstützt
und das hat sie ja auch schon getan und
jetzt ist wichtig vielleicht auch
letztlich eine plattform aufzubauen
damit alle kliniken auf diese
informationen zugreifen und sie dann
online auch einen register darstellen um
aufzuklären wer wohin also er dann mit
einer belieferung rechnen kann also ein
register für beatmungs plätze gibt es ja
das ist vorhanden aber da müssten noch
viel mehr informationen hinterlegt seien
zum beispiel eben auch nicht nur wir
hatten beatmungs platz auch wer hat
vielleicht noch weitere technische
geräte die über die die infusion gegeben
werden auch sowas kann mal knapp werden
einer klinik der sind die sehr viel mehr
intensiv kapazitäten aufbaut also wenn
wir einfach dankbar wenn gerade so eine
plattform noch mehr genutzt werden
könnte damit sich die kliniken
vielleicht auch die nah beieinander
liegen und trotzdem nicht genau wissen
was ist auch vor ort unterstützen können
und die bereitschaft ist da
man muss der austausch einfach noch ein
bisschen was auch funktioniert personal
haben sie auch schon angesprochen da
gibt es jetzt die forderung dass man
medizinstudenten rekurriert dass man
ärzte im ruhestand wieder mit in den
alltag den medizinischen alltag zurück
holt wie sind da die reaktionen sie
sagen sie haben positive resonanzen
würden sie sich noch mehr wünschen
also ich war erstmal in meiner eigenen
klinik ganz begeistert dass kolleginnen
und kollegen die den letzten jahren da
in ruhestand gegangen sind sich gleich
wieder am eigenen haus gemeldet haben
und gesagt haben wenn ihr wenn ihr
bedarf habe bitte wir kommen
das ist natürlich super weil die sind
letztlich die kennen das haus die
braucht man gar nicht mehr
viel einarbeiten aber wir bräuchten
jetzt zum beispiel für die
medizinstudentinnen und studenten
müssten
meiner meinung nach die universitäten
koordinierend tätig werden und zwar und
einfach abfragen wer ist bereit zu
helfen wer kann schon was wer hat welche
vorerfahrungen vielleicht die sind schon
rettungssanitäter und so weiter dabei
und auch dann letztlich so banale dinge
fragen wie wer ist mobil und hat
vielleicht einen fahrbaren untersatz um
auch ein krankenhaus 50 kilometer vom
wohnort weg auch da unterstützend tätig
werden
eckart von hirschhausen personal war
schon vor der krise knapp es hat
eigentlich an allen ecken und enden
innerhalb des gesundheitssystems
engpässe gegeben und jetzt natürlich in
der krise erst recht haben wir da an den
falschen stellen gespart
das haben wir ganz sicher und wenn man
versuchen will an dieser krise etwas
positives zu entdecken
wann genau die wiederentdeckung welche
berufsgruppen sind systemrelevant -
banker flugzeugbauer oder sind es
menschen die für andere da sind in
krisen und ironischerweise hatte letzte
woche der deutsche gedacht stattfinden
sollen dann musste abgesagt werden
ist die brüste plattformen um die
pflegeberufe nach vorne zu bringen wir
fordern dort weil ich da im
organisationsteam bin schon seit langem
das ist endlich eine deutsche
bundesweite pflegekammer gibt es gibt
einen ärztetag es gibt mehr ärztekammer
ist eine vertretung der pflege wirklich
dieses fallpauschalensystem wurde
unglaublich viele fehlanreize gesetzt
mehr und mehr zu machen aber
ausgerechnet bei der pflege brutal zu
sparen wenn man heute händlerin menschen
braucht die in deutschland ausgebildet
wurden dann könnte man zum beispiel der
schweiz gucken sie arbeiten ungefähr
80.000 die in deutschland so schlecht
behandelt wurden dass sie weg gegangen
sind
wie kriegen wir die wieder wie können
wir in deutschland auch lassen nach
norwegen auch ärzte sind abgewandert
das heißt also wir müssen wird die
chancen nutzen um zu denken und zu sagen
daseinsvorsorge ist was anderes als
private gewinnoptimierung im
gesundheitswesen und das ist jetzt nicht
der moment fehler zu suchen aber da sehe
ich auf alle fälle
potenzial auch die wertschätzung diesen
berufen gegenüber und auch ihre
grundsätzlichen arbeitsbedingungen
massiv zu verbessern das ist uns
wirklich jetzt jetzt dringender bewusst
aber die leute die im system sich
auskennen wussten dass seit 20 jahren
hubertus heil frage nochmal nach der
jetzigen akuten situation wie kann die
bundesregierung unterstützen noch mehr
personal zu rekrutieren die stille
reserve bundeswehr war heute schon in
den nachrichten dass da auch mit den
sanitätsdiensten der bundeswehr
gearbeitet werden kann mit den sieben
krankenhäusern sind das entscheidende
hilfen auch seitens der bundesregierung
da an die bundeswehr zu denken auch aber
ich warne so vor ein paar vorstellung
ich habe jetzt gehört das über
feldlazarette auf marktplätzen
aufgemacht wenn du das ist sicherlich
nicht richtig
wir brauchen da andere dinge und finde
ich sie richtig verstanden habe als
experte und experten die haben wir drei
mediziner die aus der praxis viele
fragen können dann müssen auf die
praktiker hören auf die wissenschaftler
sind die sagen uns mobilisiert das
personal setzt das zur entlastung von
andern einen die zb intensivmedizin
jetzt sehr gebraucht werden entlastet
die von anderen dingen und das was sie
gesagt haben findet den einzelnen
bundesländern jetzt schon statt das muss
es mehr geben so zum beispiel
medizinstudentinnen und -studenten
mobilisieren dass wir auch gucken in
welchen bereichen wir kapazitäten frei
haben wir jetzt nicht brauchen auch
dinge nicht geleistet werden müssen um
uns darauf zu konzentrieren und ich will
aber noch mal sagen das geht nicht nur
medizinerin mediziner es gibt genauso um
das zu pflegende person das fliegende
personal ganz wichtig und es geht auch
ein paar die dahinter stecken ich habe
gestern erlebt dass mir eine frau die in
der wäscherei arbeitet die für
krankenhaus wäsche macht sagt wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass meine kinder auch
notfall betreut sind wenn die kitas und
schulen jetzt geschlossen sind
ich bin auch systemrelevant wenn die
krankenhäuser dreckig werden sage ich
jetzt mal ein bisschen als laie dann
haben wir auch ein problem in der
hygiene also die da dran sind die müssen
wir unterstützen dieses nur mobilisieren
aber jeder an seinem ort und platzt und
wir müssen das richtig schnell machen
wir haben eine ganze menge dazu
ergriffen an maßnahmen vor allem das
gesundheitsministerium mit den ländern
zusammen
wichtige aufgabe haben ich versuche das
im rahmen meiner möglichkeiten
unterstützung der hersteller sie haben
vollkommen recht
selbst wenn wir das irgendwann mal
überwunden haben wenn wir nicht zum
alltag übergehen können wir werden es
auch darüber unterhalten müssen dass wir
eigentlich ein wahnsinnig tolles
öffentliches gesundheitswesen auch mit
unseren gesundheitsämtern haben die wir
jetzt erst erkennen die die ganze zeit
sind ja so wie du bist gar nicht immer
so in vielen bereichen kaputt gespart wo
er aber die wir noch haben im gegensatz
zu vielen anderen ländern
und deshalb sage ich das machen wir
später aber jetzt geht es um die akuten
fragen wie wird man mitten analysen
jetzt professor thorsten in einer echten
not würden sie auch sagen dass man für
das klinikpersonal sie arbeiten an der
charité in berlin tatsächlich auch
regeln lockern muss naja es gibt eben
zum beispiel diese regeln bei der
kinderbetreuung war wo natürlich dann
bestimmte berufsgruppen einen
betreuungsplatz weiter behalten auch
wenn eigentlich die kindertagesstätten
geschlossen sind
das ist also schon da und natürlich muss
man dafür sorgen dass diese arbeitskraft
insgesamt erhalten bleibt und da hatten
sie auch einen guten vorschlag nämlich
zu sorgen dass krankenhäuser mit
angeschlossenen instituten und laboren
eben täglich ihr personal prüft und
testet damit die weiterarbeiten können
wenn sie konstant negativ sind ja das
feld so unter das thema sinnvolle
nutzung von diagnostik kapazität nicht
man kann sich eben schon vorstellen
mitarbeiter frei zu testen für die
arbeit so dass man die nicht in
quarantäne oder isolation geben muss
gleichzeitig kann man natürlich
demnächst auch hoffen dass erste
mitarbeiter dann antikörper haben also
die krankheit schon durchgemacht haben
wäre das kann man auch im labor testen
kann man sagen dieser mitarbeiter hat
jetzt schon die infektion hinter sich
und kann im prinzip ohne
schutzausrüstung in der an die front und
ist dann auch einigermaßen immun für
eine bestimmte zeit die wenigstens ein
paar jahre umfasst vor ohne große not
man kapiert es nicht in einem so
hochentwickelten land wie unseren an
atemschutzmasken auch da sind zehn
millionen bestellt aber kein mensch weiß
wie lange das jetzt noch braucht oder
wissen sie dann mehr als wir die zehn
millionen sind da hat herr spahn
verkündet sie werden jetzt verteilt über
die länder
und über die kassenärztlichen
vereinigungen also das bringt uns
natürlich eine gewisse zeit weiter aber
wir wissen dass das nicht reicht für die
ganze zeit material ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt aber sie haben gerade
auch in ganz wichtigen punkt
angesprochen wo kann man n das personal
noch weiter entlasten einmal durch hilfe
durch andere aber auch in dem wir dinge
nicht mehr tun die wir jetzt nicht tun
müssen
dazu gehört dokumentation dazu gehört
auch das schaffen von vielen vielen
daten die wir erfassen wir wissen von
befragungen unserer mitglieder im
marburger bund also ärzte und ärzte
angeben 60 prozent sagen ich verbringe
drei stunden und mehr für
dokumentations- tätigkeiten und
verwaltungstätigkeiten dass da brauchen
wir jetzt ein signal von der politik die
sagt diese prüfungen diese vielen
sicherungsmaßnahmen die werden jetzt mal
ausgesetzt und diese hände die da am
schreibtisch sind die können wieder
zurück an den patienten und die
patientinnen und patienten versorgen und
trotzdem müssen sich die kollegen keine
sorgen machen und auch die pflege keine
sorgen machen dass das krankenhaus am
ende nicht mehr steht weil irgendwelche
zettel nicht richtig ausgefüllt sind und
deswegen ist nicht die leistung nicht
vergütet wird
also dieses signal ist wichtig das ist
für die pflege heute sich leben worden
und ich würde mir sehr wünschen das
würde für die ärztlichen kollegen
genauso gelten damit wir die kollegen
aus dem medizinischen dienst selbst wenn
sie schon lange außer
patientenversorgung raus sind können sie
unterstützen zum beispiel für die
aufklärung von patienten
am telefon und so weiter und viele
werden sich sicher auch noch zutrauen
dass er ganz kurz ad hoc sagen zu diesem
thema das mit der dokumentation ist wie
gesagt für die pflege heute gemacht
worden
kollege sparen hat das auch angekündigt
für andere bereiche und werden nächste
woche im bundestag auch etwas zur
krankenhausfinanzierung tun damit wir da
nicht schaden haben in dieser stelle
oder leute aus finanziellen gründen
bestimmte sachen unterlassen oder aus
angst von haftungsfragen
dann müssen wir schnell handeln das
werden wir auch tun so und dann ist hier
meine frage nämlich die nochmal zu
markus söder dem bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten der hat nicht nur
den katastrophenfall ausgerufen für sein
land sondern er stellt die atemmasken
jetzt auch wieder selber her damit wir
sie eben nicht mehr aus anderen ländern
der welt liefern lassen und uns damit in
eine eigentlich unmögliche abhängigkeit
gebracht haben oder wenn eine weltweite
vernetzung wir sehen das ja wir sind
exporteure und importeure von bestimmten
dingen das ist so und das wird jetzt
besonders schwierig dann übrigens auch
handelsströme unterbrochen sind da geht
es um lieferketten
es gibt firmen die bestellen bei uns
warten muss geräte her aber die hohe
fertigungstiefe von 20 prozent die sind
auch teile von anderen angewiesen
all das müssen wir im blick haben da
muss man auch unkonventionelle hand hand
anlegen und im zweifelsfall werden wir
auch über grenzen die dicht sind luft
brücken bauen müssen um die teile im
cargo-bereich nicht personen bereiche
herr zu schaffen all das ist auf dem weg
zu organisieren wenn mal ein unternehmen
nennen die jetzt im flugzeug pro jahr
folgen gesagt lufthansa hat jetzt jetzt
nicht viele passagiere zu fliegen aber
dass stellen ihre kapazitäten zur
verfügung nicht nur um deutsche
zurückzuholen die im ausland waren und
nicht weiter gekommen sind sondern auch
um im cargo bereich also im güterbereich
dafür zu sorgen dass wir die teile
brauchen und zweifelsfall um ich sag's
mal und technisch und dinge auch bei uns
schnell zusammen schrauben zu können
und auch das wird eine lehre vielleicht
für einen danach sein dass wir bestimmte
abhängigkeiten zukünftig vermeiden
sollten in diesem land gucken wir noch
mal in die situation der krankenhäuser
in europa
italiens gesundheitssystem vor dem
zusammenbruch
tausende sind bereits gestorben und die
zahlen steigen weiter vor allem in
norden italiens in zelten führen sie die
sogenannte trias durch eine vorauswahl
je nach schwere der erkrankung
beatmungsgeräte sind knapp wer also wird
zuerst behandelt wer hat die bessere
überlebenschance
pflegende und ärzte am limit es hat
einige todesfälle gegeben das macht uns
fertig war wir denken wir sind nicht in
der lage das zu tun wofür wir eigentlich
hier sind menschen zu behandeln dass es
ihnen besser geht die wirklichkeit ist
wie sehen sie sterben und innerlich
sterben wir auch überlastung
erscheinungen auch in frankreich das
militär richtet bald feldlazarette wie
diese seien besonders betroffen ist das
elsass die krankenhäuser sind überfüllt
patienten werden ausgeflogen
müssen sich auch deutsche krankenhäuser
haben gefordert dass seit vielen wochen
und nochmal ganz klar haltig wir
erwarten dass von allen ausstellern dass
sie ihre intensiv kapazitäten mindestens
verdoppeln sie haben da schon einen
blick durch die lupe auch uns und dem
zuschauer gestattet es gibt jetzt die
nachricht von berlin eine sogenannte
überlauf klinik schaffen zu wollen
messehalle messegelände 26 1000 betten
der hinweis von hubertus heil wäre meine
frage an sie wie sinnvoll ist dass das
wir jetzt tatsächlich sogenannte spot
bauen krankenhäuser die eben überlauf
kapazitäten überlauf krankenhäuser sein
sollen um die eben eine schwerpunkt
behandlung zu ermöglichen halten sie das
für sinnvoll
also wenn es nötig ist und wir so viele
patienten haben dann
kann man darüber nachdenken ob man das
tut aber letztendlich sollten wir
zunächst alle kapazitäten die wir haben
und dazu gehören zum beispiel auch
rehabilitationskliniken optimal
ausstatten und nutzen wenn wir sehen
dass wir jetzt schon in manchen
bereichen materialknappheit haben
dann hilft es natürlich nicht dass
wenige material auf noch mehr standorte
zu verteilen sondern ich sollte lieber
die häuser die wir haben
optimal ertüchtigen mit personal mit
material mit allen unterstützung mit mit
studenten die helfen mit kollegen die
helfen den ruhestand sind alle all das
ist glaube ich der erste sein lüge
hüller neue infrastruktur zu bauen und
so ein bisschen wandern auch in
deutschland zu probieren soll ja wir
haben ist die eigentliche lehre gezogen
so ist die reha klinik will er aber das
würde alles mobilisieren
gut wir sind besonders ergriffen
professor thorsten von natürlich dem was
in italien und in frankreich
mittlerweile nötig ist nämlich dass man
rationiert und priorisiert in bezug auf
lebensrettende maßnahmen das will man
sich nicht vorstellen
droht das auch uns ja das ist dann
tatsächlich eine frage der zahlen also
ob man das tatsächlich schafft jetzt mit
guter effizienz dass die verbreitung
also die kurve zu verkleinern
und natürlich gibt es auch andere dinge
die da rein spielen also ist es ist
schon so dass wir in deutschland eine
hohe zahl von intensiv und beatmungs
plätzen schon haben in der
grundausstattung dass wir natürlich
jetzt diese vorbereitungszeit haben also
so eine talkrunde im vorlauf hat es in
italien nicht gegeben die waren
plötzlich in der situation und wir haben
mehrere wochen von von diesem vorlauf
jetzt es sind auch vielleicht dinge die
man nicht so im detail sieht ich habe
jetzt in den letzten tagen fiel auch mit
intensivmedizinern gesprochen und mir
ist eigentlich klar geworden dass auch
diese erkrankung besonders schwierig zu
beatmen ist und das man intensiv medizin
da wirklich können muss und ich glaube
wir sind schon gut in diesem handwerk in
deutschland
das ist aber dann auch wieder eine frage
von fortbildung zum teil auch ad hoc
nochmal fortbildung und auffrischung und
auch dafür haben wir jetzt einen
zeitlichen vorlauf den anderen ländern
nicht haben und den wir unbedingt nutzen
müssen und das ist auch immer wieder der
unterschied zu ländern wie italien in
italien gibt es leitlinien für
intensivmediziner frau in denen
altersgrenzen der behandlung steht auch
das kann man sich eigentlich nicht
vorstellen
am ende liegt die verantwortung dann
beim einzelnen arzt in so einer
situation am ende müssen wir natürlich
nach medizinischen kriterien entscheiden
und die triage ist ja ein instrument was
uns sagt welcher patient muss zuerst
behandelt werden welcher ist am
dringlichsten und kann aber natürlich
auch zu einem instrument werden was er
denn wirklich man entscheiden muss wer
hat die größten chancen von der therapie
zu profitieren aber in die situation
wollen wir natürlich möglichst gar nicht
kommen müssen denn wir möchten gerne
jedem der die intensivtherapie braucht
sie auch ermöglichen und diese optimal
wie möglich leisten und deswegen ist die
vorbereitung so wichtig deswegen ist
aber auch wichtig dass wir jetzt sagen
auch alle anderen patienten chronisch
kranke patienten leider machen die
anderen krankheiten ja nicht pause
während der korona krise dass die auch
jetzt besonders auf sich achten dass die
niedergelassenen kollegen versuchen
jeden so gut wie es geht zu
stabilisieren ohne krankenhaus therapie
auch das wird natürlich die
krankenhäuser entlasten und insofern im
zweifelsfall müssen wir als ärzte solche
entscheidungen treffen die treffen wir
auch in der notaufnahme in mit der frage
wen behandeln dich zuerst wenn viele
patienten auf einmal kommen
aber das entscheidende ist die
ressourcen jetzt so einzuteilen dass wir
möglichst selten solche schwerwiegende
entscheidungen treffen müssen muss man
noch mal mit blick auf die deutsche
öffentlichkeit eckart von hirschhausen
sagen und sehr bitter sagen braucht es
erst solche schrecklichen bilder aus
deutschen krankenhäusern damit wirklich
auch der letzte kapiert worum es geht
ich hoffe sehr dass wir
ohne zwangsmaßnahmen in freien land
hinkommen aber ich habe hier müssen wir
uns alle sehr erwachsen verhalten und
der mangel
es werden in deutschland in den nächsten
wochen menschen sterben und die werden
nicht sterben an mangel an klopapier wie
man gerade irgendwie im medien nimmt
sondern sie werden sterben an mangel an
gesundem menschenverstand
sie werden sterben an mangel an
beatmungsgeräten und an mangel an
ausgebildeten menschen die da dienst tun
und das dilemma was wir psychologisch
auch haben ich habe mich damit konya
batch ausgetauscht die gerade sie auch
die ängsten der bevölkerung müssten auch
das wissen was inzwischen wächst gott
sei dank aber die übersetzung in das
verhalten
da mangelt es noch und das hat eben
nicht nur was mit kurven verstehen zu
tun sondern auch zu verstehen das ist
jetzt eine herzensangelegenheit dafür
müssen wir auch wilde haben die
klarmachen es geht potenziell immer auch
um einen selber und auch um jemand der
am lieb ist beispiel
natürlich sind die großen kinder
medizinisch herzinfarkt schlaganfall die
machen jetzt keine pause sudthoff druck
und die risikofaktoren bleiben ja vieles
davon kann man gut behandeln aber was
denn die intensivstation voll ist wen
weiß man ab die situation wollen wir uns
alle nicht vorstellen aber da werden wir
hinkommen und wie schlimm es wird das
haben wir jetzt noch zum teil in der
hand und deswegen wirklich großes
zeichen von liebe ist im moment abstand
zu halten so abstrus das ist für uns als
soziale wesen wir wollen menschen und
den arm nehmen wir wollen nah sein und
gott sei dank gibt es ja die die
digitalen möglichkeiten jemanden auch
über distanz zu zeigen dass man an ihn
denkt aber dass ernst zu nehmen das ist
das gebot der stunde und auf eine
kuriose art und weise entdecken der
dinge wieder die schon immer gegolten
haben also händewaschen war auch schon
vor zeiten von corona sinnvoll aber
jetzt erst mal sozial ist digital
wenigstens jetzt hubertus heil ärzte und
krankenschwestern können sich gerade
nicht retten vorarbeiten und andere
werden immer weniger davon haben sie
sagen die deutsche bundesregierung sagt
wir wollen dass niemand seine existenz
verliert das ist ein großer satz nimmt
der staat den mund da ein bisschen
zufall
ich will das mal versuchen ein bisschen
auch für uns alle zu sortieren
man muss in solchen situationen
prioritäten setzen
priorität liegt auf gesundheitsschutz um
das nicht zu erleben was wir in italien
sehen im zweifelsfall vorrang vor
wirtschaftlichen interessen wir zahlen
gerade auch wirtschaftlich jetzt schon
und auf längere sicht einen sehr hohen
preis
aber es ist der preis zum retten von
menschenleben und das muss man deutlich
sagen
gleichwohl ist meine aufgabe als
arbeitsminister mit anderen kollegen
auch zu sagen wenn die menschen die
schon existenzielle ängste um ihre
gesundheit und ihr leben haben dann
lasst uns versuchen dass wir ihn andere
ängste wo immer es geht durch sicherung
aufzuhalten ist und deshalb kämpfen
diese ängste sind enorm das wissen sie
sie haben sehr schnell mit dieser
kurzarbeiterregelung und mit einer
unkonventionellen regelung reagiert das
sind 60 prozent des normalen lohns davon
können viele nicht klippen das fliegen
in schlecht bezahlten berufen also erst
einmal halten die menschen in arbeit es
gibt 60 prozent für familien übrigen 67
prozent und die arbeitgeber kriegen alle
sozialversicherungsbeiträge und ich
erwarte auch von vielen dass sie da von
ihren arbeitnehmern auch was abgeben wo
tarifverträge sind es das übrigens der
freie
aber wir haben ganz viele menschen die
dann in kurzarbeit kommen werden nicht
vollzeit arbeit nicht viel verdienen die
so an den rand der existenz kommen
können und deshalb werde in der nächsten
woche dafür sorgen dass die auch
ergänzende grundsicherung bekommen damit
sie über die runden kommen das gilt
übrigens auch für kleine selbstständig
für kleinst selbständige ohnehin immer
ein dünnes einkommen haben deren
existenz müssen wir wirtschaftlich
erhalten dazu gibt es nächste woche auch
maßnahmen von peter altmaier olaf scholz
und zwar nicht nur kredite sondern es
muss auch direkte hilfen geben weil die
laufende kosten haben die umsätze
wegbrechen wenn sie jetzt händler sind
oder wenn sie beispielsweise im
kreativen bereich sind her chancen kennt
das sehr sehr gut und viele andere auch
oder wenn wir eigentlich sehr viele
andere sachen
aber ich sage nochmal die veränderten
regeln zur kurzarbeit für die wir jetzt
erst einmal 26 milliarden euro haben sie
haben uns schon mal in einer krise
geholfen ganz vielen großen und kleinen
läden auch vielen kleinen genau das sind
die fest angestellten arbeitnehmer
bleiben wir vielleicht noch mal eine
sekunde bei den solo selbstständigen sie
haben schon gesagt das ist ein riesiger
bereich das ist die klavier
genauso wie der coach und wie der
künstler die sind auf hartz 4 wenn sie
keine aufträge bekommen die brauchen
jetzt nicht ein kredit die brauchen
liquidität also es gibt die queen arena
44 dinge ganz konkrete sachen die helfen
nicht immer allen allen aber eine sache
ist sofort ans finanzamt wenden
steuervorauszahlung kürzen
das zweite ist es gibt liquiditätshilfen
mit der hausbank reden dass die den
haaren nicht abdrehen weil die kfw jetzt
sichert das dritte sind jetzt direkte
zuschüsse die wir organisieren werden
und das vierte ist wenn jemand wirklich
existenz gefährdet ist aber sein betrieb
noch hat oder seine solo selbständigkeit
dann kann er um über die runden zu
kommen ich rede von solchen fällen wo es
ganz kalt ist auch ergänzende
grundsicherung bekommen und wir werden
dafür sorgen dass das ohne bürokratie
und vermögensprüfung läuft und damit die
existenz gesichert ist wir müssen aber
auch handwerkern helfen was im moment
erleben sind kleinstbetriebe solo
selbstständige aber auch betriebe bis
zehn beschäftigte problem haben und
nicht nach ein noch aus wissen und den
werden wir wo immer es geht helfen und
wir haben ich habe mich gestern
übertroffen mit einem möglichen
vertretern unterschiedlichster bereiche
und da hat mir eine frau erzählt die
alleinerziehend ist die clans
kleingewerbe hat an diesem punkt was sie
jetzt an sorgen hat um ihre kinder zu
versorgen
ich will dass wir diese sorgen nehmen
jeder hat wenn die wirtschaftliche
existenz gefährdet ist man nicht über
die runden kommt in diesem land anrecht
auf eine ordentliche grundsicherung wir
sind nicht in amerika wo die menschen
ins bodenlose fallen in solchen
situationen sondern wir müssen unseren
sozialstaat wir werden das nächste woche
so unbürokratisch gestalten dass die
hilfen auch schnell ankommen die kassen
sind voll
christian lindner vorsitzender der fdp
schlägt eine negativsteuer vor um den
menschen jetzt tatsächlich zu helfen und
ihnen nicht zu sagen geh mal zu einer
bank und beantrage einen kredit sondern
was es jetzt braucht ist wirklich
liquidität was würden sie sagen sie
haben schon erwähnt sie werden jetzt
eigentlich auf tour mit euch gibt es
auch tour techniker und ist ja gibt solo
selbstständige also der
meine lernkurve über die letzten zwei
drei wochen war auch hart weil ich
ähnlich wie wahrscheinlich viele
zuschauer am anfang dachte ist diese
ganze aufregung wirklich notwendig
inzwischen auch dank durch ihren
wunderbar antwort gast beim ndr
da haben sie mich überzeugt wie
veranstaltungen abzublasen waren
notwendig allerdings hängen ja
unglaublich viele menschen dran
ich habe heute ein aufruf gekriegt von
der lit.cologne freund von uns
organisiert das ein ganz kleiner sozial
sozusagen solidarbeitrag könnte sein
wenn man tickets gekauft hat die einfach
nicht zurückzufordern
warum weil kosten angefallen sind die
veranstalter haben im hallen gemäht das
alles fällt weg die auftreten wenn die
autoren die künstler gehen leer aus aber
zählenden technik genau meine ganze
technik crew die hersteller auch grüße
dir den fallen ja auch die ganzen
aufträge weg das heißt also da können
wir auch
wir müssen uns sagen aus dieser panik
auch aus kriegen in was für eine welt
wollen wir denn danach kommen und da ist
auch kultur nicht einfach nur pipifax
auf dass man ganz einfach verzichten
sondern demokratie lebt von dem
austausch dass man sich irgendwo treffen
kann dafür braucht das auto dafür
braucht es menschen die auch mit viel
idealismus und herzblut unterwegs und
die dürfen wir auch in diesen zeiten
jetzt unbedingt der unbedingt und die
tickets nicht zurück zu fordern oder das
geld dafür nicht sondern auch gefordert
eine geste und wir sind noch mal bei der
liquidität der leute hubertus heil
letzte frage dazu
der münchner ob appelliert an die
wohnungseigentümer ja bitte kündigt
nicht absolut was machen wir mit mietern
die jetzt auch auf ihr konto gucken und
sagen es reicht noch für zwei monate
aber nicht für 7 wir werden zwei dinge
tun das eine ist gerade auch bei
gewerbetreibenden wo die laufenden
kosten mietkosten zum beispiel für ein
kleines geschäft weiterlaufen die
umsätze wegbrechen werden wir hilfen
geben dass man das auch hinkriegen kann
das zweite ist wir müssen auch
wahrscheinlich kurzfristig also
mietrecht tun damit jetzt diese verträge
nicht gegründet wird und wir werden ganz
konkret auch das wohngeld anfassen
müssen
das sage ich an dieser stelle das sind
drei wichtige maßnahmen nicht die
letzten die wir haben
aber ich sag das deshalb weil in vielen
bereichen jetzt menschen sich alle
möglichen ängste gleichzeitig machen das
wichtigste ist der schutz der gesundheit
das zweite ist die soziale sicherheit
und die arbeitsplätze
ich sage übrigens nicht und kann nicht
versprechen dass wir am ende wirklich
jeden arbeitsplatz gerettet haben das
kann man nicht brechen die umsätze weg
aber wir kämpfen um jeden arbeitsplatz
und wir sichern jeder existenz auch
wirtschaftlich ab das kann dieses land
das haben den anderen zeiten ganz andere
probleme gehabt das können wir besser
möglicherweise als andere nicht aus
überheblichkeit aber ich kenne keinen
staat in der welt fast kein vielleicht
mal ein bisschen wie die scandinavia die
einen ausgebauten sozialstaat haben der
muss nur unbürokratisch und schnell
funktionieren und daran arbeiten wir
jetzt mit hochdruck und zwar ganz ganz
schnell
christian drosten man muss es verstehen
das interesse der mediziner ihr
interesse ist dass das ein möglichst
langer prozess ist dass wir die
infektionen möglichst lange hinauszögern
das interesse der politik und eigentlich
irgendwie auch jedes normalen menschen
ist natürlich es so kurz wie möglich zu
halten hat man in einer solchen
ausnahmesituation überhaupt spielraum
ja das ist tatsächlich das eigentliche
wirklich schwierige hier an also wir
müssen jetzt für den moment also für die
nächsten monate unter diese
belastungsgrenze des gesundheitssystems
kommt aber dann ist die frage wie geht
es weiter wie lange soll man das dann
noch durchhalten
und da gibt es modellrechnungen die
sagen zwei jahre und das ist natürlich
nicht durchzuhalten und wir müssen da
irgendwann auch in und zwar auch
dringend in einem diskussionsprozess
einsteigen um das ganze auch mit anderen
mitteln zu lösen also wir sprechen ja
hier bei dieser maßnahme jetzt von
sozialen distanzierung und so weiter das
sind alles nicht pharmazeutische
interventionen
es gibt aber auch pharmazeutische
interventionen die das ist die große
hoffnung auf medikamente sind
medikamente oder impfstoffe und
natürlich ist es jetzt nicht einfach da
was aus dem ärmel zu schütteln
bei den medikamenten da gibt es
natürlich kandidaten aber die
zulassungsprozesse da sind wirklich
kompliziert und langwierig da müsste man
also tatsächlich er jetzt nochmal
substanzen genau anschauen
die zugelassen sind die man umwidmen
kann da ist also gerade die wissenschaft
wirklich fieberhaft dabei aber es gibt
da leider noch keine sehr guten
nachrichten
es geht ja es ist das geht auch die
ganze zeit wäre all dieses ebola
medikamente sieben rennen die sie mir
meine güte ist das aussichtsreich oder
sagen sie viel aussichtsreicher ist der
kampf eben um einen impfstoff das revier
ist eine interessante substanz die ist
ja noch nicht ganz zugelassen
die kann man jetzt unter sogenannten
compassionate use protokollen benutzen
der hersteller gibt diese substanz aber
nur frei auf beantragung für den
jeweiligen patienten der patienten muss
kurz beschrieben werden und dann muss
der patient in einem zustand sein wo man
sagen sagt der braucht schon sauerstoff
aber er braucht noch keine kreislauf
unterstützenden medikamente auf der
intensivstation und in diesem fenster
gibt die firma im moment die substanz
frei viele ärzte würden sich eigentlich
wünschen dass man die substanz früher im
verlauf geben könnte wo der patient
vielleicht mehr davon hat die
replikation eines virus zu blockieren
aber das würde dann viel mehr patienten
betreffen und ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob es so viel substanz überhaupt schon
gibt von diesem von dieser diesem
medikament und außerdem muss man jetzt
auch die zulassungsstudien bedingungen
richtig einhalten sonst wird das
komplizierter und komplizierter das
robert koch institut rechnet mit einem
impfstoff nicht vor frühjahr 2021
dietmar hopp der mehrheitseigner diese
tübinger firma von biotech hat jetzt den
herbst avisiert was sagen sie ja also
ich will da jetzt nicht von einzelnen
produkten sprechen dazu kenne ich mich
dazu auch gar nicht genug aus ich bin
kein impfstoff forscher in dem sinne ich
habe da vielleicht erst ein bisschen
breite allgemeine kenntnis ich habe
schon das gefühl dass wir sicherlich in
einem gut informierten kreis auch andere
optionen diskutieren müssen also
ohne da jetzt in irgendwelche details
einzusteigen aber es gibt natürlich
gerade im impfstoffbereich eine große
große sicherheitsanforderung wir wollen
nichts verkaufen was die leute mit zu
nebenwirkungen versieht und vielleicht
irgend welche wirkungen auslöst die man
nicht will
nur die frage ist bei einer
patientengruppe die vielleicht ein
risiko hat zu sterben das fast an 10%
herangeht
da muss man natürlich auch noch ein
zweites mal nachdenken über impfstoffe
die begleiterscheinungen machen im
bereich von 1 2000 oder so oder sogar
noch weniger
das ist etwas das man heute bei der
impfstoff zulassung niemals tolerieren
würde
eine nebenwirkung in diesem bereich eine
schwere nebenwirkung
aber wir haben ja nichts anderes wir
können das ja nicht zwei jahre
durchhalten können müssen irgendwie da
mal drüber nachdenken